you became really famous during this
time with krock it was like the biggest
station out there you're doing this new
wave you're doing music you love you're
introducing um you know one of the
biggest music scenes in the in the world
to a British music new way music
alternative music and in doing so you
were sort of like I said before the
conduit did you did you you formed huge
relationships I mean I saw an interview
where you're you know after Andrew
Fletcher of dep PES mode passed away
and uh God Rest his soul you you uh you
knew him and you know you were texting
with Martin Gore who wrote All the PES
mode songs and still does and and he's
texting you right back and you have this
relationship with so many people and you
know you you dated the beautiful Terry
nun from Berlin take my breath away and
you had a passionate relationship with
her um all these relationships were you
did you ever get to a point were you
mixed up in drugs were you mixed up in
the scene were you drinking a lot did
you always have a good head on your
shoulders or were you uh were you
enjoying it like everybody else and
getting in too much getting too deep I
never did drugs I drank I two times I
mean I did cocaine twice uh I never with
who one time uh it was with a record
company geek and uh a couple of bands in
Riverside the other time I was doing TV
show called mv3 and the producer of it I
mean the show was a hit it was on in 50
cities it was massive in LA and the
producer put it up his nose but what
happened he had a little uh studio in
Burbank a Sound Stage it was a converted
Chinese Laundry uh that he made into a
Sound Stage he owned it himself so he
had the potential to make nothing but
money because he had you know no costs
Etc but he was not delivering on time
right and we at one point had the
psyched Furs there on stage and 100
dancers and the Psychedelic Furs this
was in June and the sun was baking down
June of 1983 okay sun was baking down on
this you know tin roof and the air
conditioning was cranking and it was the
Big H hallogen lights not LED hallogen
lights heating everything up and The
Furs were there and Richard Butler in
his long coat and the dancer's body he
it was just it was crazy it was getting
hot and sweaty and they done their sound
check and for an hour they were just
standing on stage and the dancers were
Milling around and the floor manager
finally said to me he goes if we don't
roll tape we're going to lose the band
he said we got to do something I said
well why isn't he rolling tape the guy
upstairs you know the producer he says
[__] you know what he's like he said go
you go up he'll listen to you cuz that's
one of the three hosts but at that point
I was the actually One Two Hosts one had
quit already and so I went up to see him
and I walk into his uh little edit Bay
Studio which was upstairs so he could
look down through the glass and see
everything and call edits and cuts and
which camera we had three cameras
shooting and I walk in and to me in
hindsight and I'm sure it wasn't this
big there was a mound of coke like in
Scarface on his desk but I'm sure it's
probably fist size but to me it was you
know small Everest and next to it a
snubnose 38
because the teamsters have been coming
around repossessing some of the cameras
and they'd already taken out the crane
right and so uh I said we have to roll
tape or we lose the band and he goes
listen Daddy because he's his vocal tick
everyone was Daddy listen Daddy I'll
roll tape if you do a line with me I
said I can't do that I said I go be on
camera he goes you need it or make you
better I'm like if I do a line will you
roll tape
and he said I'll roll it if you do
online so I said okay he gets this I
don't know 520 whatever it was rolled up
he does a sniff first so I go down and
do it and I'm like I I'm expecting rain
rainbows and unicorns and all I get is
I'm grinding my back teeth cuz I'm
naturally hyper anyway like okay let's
roll tape he goes do another line I said
that wasn't the deal you said I'd do a
line and we'd roll tape and he go why
don't you get the [__] out of here and
you tell them to roll tape yourself you
can do that right and I went okay and I
went down I said all right roll tape and
then from then on it was me and a guy
called Peter facer you know I think you
metet yeah that would call all the rolls
because uh the producer director didn't
do it two months later the show went off
the air but she Jesus